[Music]
there's a hong kong actress her name's
francesca wong she recently gave a
public apology
for portraying a filipino maid in a
recent tv role so she filipino faced
herself she filipino faced herself she
put on brown face how do you feel about
this that's brown as a brown man how do
you feel about these chinese brown
facers
because as a yellow face i think it's
100 okay because he's a yellow fan i
think it's not okay at all i don't think
you should do any brown face as a pale
face i don't think i don't know am i
japanese
is it a good impression
that's
i want to see so here's the thing
usually like
my my feeling is 100 based on just how
the performance right here
or like or what the reason or what the
context so i'll just let you guys see it
first oh there's video all right oh
there is video so here she is getting
ready for the roll is the tropic thunder
of the philippines it's tropic thunder
robert downey jr killed this wait this
is a hong kong movie it's a it's a hong
kong tv show yeah yeah yeah genius is it
what is it a is it a drama oh it's a
drama they paint her face look at my mom
watch this
bruh
oh she's supposed to be crazy it's a
horror movie it might be i don't know oh
so she's supposed to be like a crazy
maid yeah it's just filipino
i just realized what she was doing
what is she doing by the way
she's browning her legs yeah and also
why doesn't the makeup artist do this
like is this a low budget she's method
acting and they're making her do
everything herself she's filipino but
the um but the crazy thing is she's
talking in a filipino accent in this
moment that's that's what i thought she
was her best accent like let's listen to
it what is it
she says chinese sounds like singaporean
yeah she's south singaporean or
malaysian or something it sounds like
she's trying to do this i didn't think
she was trying at that point i didn't
either know i didn't think she was
trying to i thought that was shoes i
thought that was a chinese accent that's
what i thought so people are getting mad
at her oh yeah
the network apologized and everything
all the white people are mad though huh
i think all the uh all the neck shark
commenters are mad
here here's a photo of the uh thing
that's a cute dog is it a filipino
family
no it's not a filipino family it's like
she's just the healthiest true there's a
ton of filipinos in hong kong yeah
there's a ton of filipino actors in hong
kong when i went to hong kong
there's like a [ __ ] ton of filipinos
that just chill on at the park on sunday
they're just like so you're trying to
say they have no jobs
you
it was one of the days of the week i was
like why is there so many [ __ ]
filipinos and apparently like it's like
a thing like like they miss the
philippines or something and then they
just like they like to go to the park
together and just [ __ ] chill and then
like have a picnic and [ __ ] i was
like that's some community [ __ ] that's
tight yeah they should act
that's i think that's like there's so
many there's so many things about like
what people are mad at there's a number
of things some of them that it's just
unnecessary yeah because like there's so
many things especially nowadays so this
actress in particular already kind of
looks
more filipino like just her eyes you
know everything like she doesn't need to
darken herself right she that's kind of
unnecessary to make yourself i know
right because what's weird is that
is it filipino like
they could be pale like a geisha in a
[ __ ] dark dark exactly it could be
all there's a huge color spectrum but
what they're going for and what what is
harmful to the filipino community out
there is they're they're purposefully
making her look as low-class filipino as
possible especially with the mates
though there's a lot of weird [ __ ] with
the maids and how they live which i
understand is because the first time i
went to singapore um you see it
everywhere yeah i didn't know that it
was like this was like a long long time
ago it was like 2005 my first time going
to singapore and then uh
i think that was the time i went too
yeah the dude was like the guy that was
hosting me he was this indian guy really
great dude um and he had a great sense
of like a very dark humor and he was
just like he goes you never seen
filipinos in singapore have you and i
was like no i haven't why and he goes
what do you think they do out here
and i was like i don't know they're
nurses like they are back where i'm from
and he goes try again
i was like um i don't know their
respiratory tech
he goes close he goes if it's a guy he's
definitely in construction if it's a
girl probably a hooker and i was like
wow are you [ __ ] serious and then
like he took me around and that is what
i saw wow and i was like holy [ __ ] so no
nurses no i mean there are but like this
like i also forgot that i totally didn't
know the stereotype for filipinos would
be different every country there is oh
because generally it's not a nurse was a
worldwide thing i know so did i and it's
no it's no surprise the country's poor
so they're going to try to take work
wherever they can get it and you know
because japanese is pretty much
pervert or anime maker
all over the world it's kind of
consistent anime so i don't have to
joe's speaking on behalf of all the
japanese people yeah
i don't face the same discrimination
because
it's either oh i love [ __ ] pokemon
or they're like
man you probably like weird technical
porn you know like that's the kind of
thing like that's the spectrum and
they're right both ways yourself isn't
at the top of the list too no i think we
eat it but not we're not the man you
know they never assume that you're the
chef
they always go oh you like to eat it huh
yeah oh you like to eat sushi huh and i
think in the 90s it was you know karate
right you know karate but like now
you're wearing your ghee under that yeah
yeah so it is like super offensive to
filipinos i think all around the world
that's not a good look if you're gonna
feature a filipino in the show like
that's the thing they gotta do like and
they're making her go that far to like
be as like oh let's make her look like
the bottom of the barrel like
culturally hong kong director he goes
she's not dark enough
go back there get more
i don't believe you man i don't believe
you know something about you don't
scream filipino yet
should have a filipino accent in the
movie or the yeah she has like this
[ __ ] whack one it's like was it the
one that she was oh dude pretty much
actually nest long yeah she has a really
long apology but basically she's just
saying i sincerely apologize and to
anyone that was negatively affected by
it and you know now we know rock
the the show is called barack oh karma
with a show name like that always on
that j channel on those uh drama like uh
yeah the rama's like c drama they always
got some weird [ __ ] names yeah like
the english translation is always like
what the [ __ ]
did your did your parents used to watch
jay channel growing up yeah this is one
like but they're always like the period
piece ones yeah yeah yeah
like the [ __ ] kung fu soap operas
yeah yeah but it's about the drama it's
like it would be like uh between like
two generals but it's really about the
the drama and [ __ ] i'm like what the
[ __ ] are they gonna fight yeah my mom's
like it's not about that
it's about the love she's always
whispering when she says it too you know
what's funny though to play to play
devil's advocate in this whole thing
the uh a double standard about this by
the way filipino's super mad about it
right philippines super mad about it
she's made herself darker than every
filipino actor that the philippines
actually makes actors because the skin
color is definitely the philippines
itself also views lighter-skinned
filipinos as like superior in
entertainment is is philippines even
like um like you know
yeah latin country you know how they
have the hottest spanish-looking women
and then like
and even in their own soap operas like
the native mexican or latin women or the
maids or whatever yeah they're not like
they're always like super light skinned
like the [ __ ] family guy page
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like some
colonial brainwashing yeah
it's a little bit weird that like
is it is it is it that or
that's just what's what's happening
you don't mean so like so for example
right like the latin stuff
it is true even if you see like who's
who's like in politics who the rich
people are they're all more
anglo-looking people like it's a more
reflection of real life rather than bad
intentions exactly and in like so like
if you're gonna make a story about
what's happening in hong kong like there
are filipino laborers right oh hundred
percent
is it that hard to find a filipino actor
no it's that's that's the thing too is
there's there's actors already in hong
kong that are filipino that could have
done it i don't know if they but also
she did a sorry job i think if she
crushed it you want me to show you the
only part where i think she crushed it
yeah let's see it she um it's a
non-speaking scene it actually is
when she's doing a break dancing
that's the part she kills it she's
breaking
she's good she does karaoke [ __ ]
and she shines she kills oh my god
it's this uh shot right here where um
thank you because right when he saw it
he knew oh
what is it look at this smile that she
has on the camera
that is 100 percent the [ __ ]
authentic genuine filipino
that's gilbert alone right there that's
the same [ __ ] i didn't like it
right the one that one asian kid
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like filipino
the minute they make them do like some
[ __ ] stereotypical like
weird face
or you they'd hit the gong i don't know
if she's trying to do it but that's
that's i feel like filipinos [ __ ]
invented this that's why she looks like
she's being racist
i gotta put a hand light right here oh
because of the teeth thing yeah i don't
know i mean filipinos they have like
that funny face that they they put their
head down they go
[Laughter]
you know it's like a thing and i'm like
if she meant to do that then she gets a
one out of ten
you know
i still think i still think it is an
interesting thing whenever filipinos are
mad about like oh making a person that
dark like but in their old exactly in
their own country there's such a clear
distinction look how many products are
for skin whitening yeah you know like as
soon as you get an agent they're like
well you got to get lighter i'm too dark
to be a [ __ ] filipino actor like
it's crazy how white you have to be you
know we had a filipino guy in our
editing team byron and he was light as a
geisha
and and and ironically he's in japan
right now studying to be a geisha
no he's teaching
he's in japan right now
[Music]
[Music]
you